this year 15 years since high school
musical two does that blow your mind
it does yeah
it's so weird i'm like it does feel like
lifetimes ago genuinely um but the fact
is kids are still watching it kids are
still being introduced to it and like i
just heard gotta go my own way is
trending on tick tock
it never dies thanks to you guys
here's to the future
no
mr
[Music]
they're part of you that's like i mean
there's a love for that with that too
yeah i mean like the fact is is i would
not
have been into musical theater if it
wasn't for natalie wood and west side
story and like she will always be maria
to me and i mean she's also gypsy rose
lee which was an icon um but like it was
because of those films that really
ignited my love for the arts and so i
feel like high school musical has done
that for the new generation
so i'm like if that's something that i
received from natalie wood i'm more than
happy to pass it along to to the kids
vanessa hudgens hosting this year's mtv
movie and tv awards how excited are you
is this a gig you love it is it's so
much fun i mean like me and my friends
celebrate things that are happening in
pop culture all the time and nobody does
that better than mtv perfect um now we
hear from everybody these awards show
gigs sometimes a little nerve-wracking
you gotta you know played everybody in
the crowd how do you handle it and is
there anybody you get advice from on how
to do it um no there's no one i get
advice
i'm like still waiting for this magical
mentor to appear to me and it hasn't
happened um but you know like i grew up
doing live theater and i live for live
events whether that's like
hosting on the carpets for the oscars or
doing grease or rent live the met gala
or the mecca yeah exactly and like it's
it's so much fun i i love that anything
can happen at any given moment and i'm
there to pick up the slack um i'm here
i'm here for the good times it's gonna
be a party you look incredible and of
course we ask every awards show host how
many outfit changes are we doing there's
gonna be a few uh to be honest we
haven't even gotten down to the
specifics of how many yet um we're
trying to not freak out about it it's
fine it'll all work out it always does
so we're days away i know i know but you
know that's just how it is sometimes
well as you said it's all about the
movies the tv that we are all obsessed
with so what movies and tv shows have
you been obsessed with over the past
year i mean i really loved batman i'm
like such a big fan of the batman series
and especially catwoman um you know i
have kept seeing this meme
saying it took robert pattinson 13 years
to go from vampire to bat and it just
like makes it even better for me
personally i love it um but like
inventing anna i love
him and tommy and of course euphoria
with the rest of the world so there's so
much to celebrate so much to celebrate
and we also have a one miss jennifer
lopez getting the generation award how
much does she deserve this honor so much
i mean i have a deep love for her
because she played my mom in second act
so i always think of her as family
but she's such an icon and she just
keeps on going i don't know anyone who
works harder than she does and i just
really admire her her workforce but also
just her and what she is to the world
you know i adore her well as somebody
who's worked with her you know a little
more than the jlo we all know what is it
that you just love most about her as a
person what's your favorite quality
um she's really kind and caring i mean
like granted she played my mom so of
course she's gonna be extremely kind and
caring with me um but like she's just
such an icon you know she doesn't really
like shy away from who she is she lets
it really all shine and she does so in a
way that's so
exciting and graceful
yeah
um and of course will we get ben affleck
in the crowd cheering no right we better
i mean you're a pop culture fan like how
much do you love that benefit is back
it's so iconic it's so iconic i'm so
here for it i love love so much so to
see her happy and in love that's that's
that's the goal we saw you and your man
hit up a couple awards shows earlier
this year is he gonna be there on sunday
supporting you know it's baseball season
so now right now but he will definitely
be watching
yeah um so tell us a little bit about
just what we can expect are there big
moments to tease that we don't know
about yet even if you can't tell us
everything yeah there's a new reward
which is very exciting i'll just say it
goes in the realm of best kiss um which
is always such an amazing award one that
has had so many iconic moments like that
um ryan gosling and rachel mcadams this
case like it's so iconic um i've got
snoop as my dj so we're gonna have a
good time up on that stage together okay
i gotta circle back bet in the vein of
best kiss my the back of my brain's been
thinking what is this new award
you're just going to have to wait and
find out it's steamy
best steamy scene
i mean look
okay i'm getting excited um we got to
ask you about a couple other your
hosting gigs real quick so you did the
met
gala red carpet this year what an iconic
moment what was your favorite part of it
whether it was somebody you interviewed
what will you never forget um i
have been a long time fan of anderson
park i just adore him he is such an
insane talent to sit on those drums and
sing the songs at the same time i'm just
always in awe of him and when he came up
he was just so sweet and he was in his
silk sonic look and i'm just like such a
fan of him and his vibe and so to be
able to talk and chat with him it was
really special for me
and i mean you love love we witnessed
like kim and pete making their debut was
that iconic yeah i i was like tucked
away in a corner i never got to see any
of it i was just like i'm working for
everybody to come over and say hello
we also know you you have a history with
so you think you can dance um we have
found out matthew morrison won't be on
the show anymore could we ever see you
on the show again could you step up
there who knows i mean like there's so
many things going on so i feel like
timing is everything
but i had the best time doing that it
was so much fun i've genuinely loved
every second of it just celebrating art
and talent is always a fantastic thing
to do
[Music]
you